french chef alain de hoes at work in the
paris restaurant that bears her name she
also heads a 2-star restaurant in London
da hoes specializes in the spicy cuisine
of southwestern France with influence
from the Basque region Britain's
restaurant magazine named her the
world's best female chef for 2015 that's
awesome yes you'll need an award changed
a lot in my life I had more customers
that my two restaurants and it changed
my image and my clientele session drum
say some songs oh sheila la composition
to vote Roxy on now people come from all
over the world we don't usually it's a
case of life before the awards and after
the award ya bein a yahoo and I've only
and I crazy care Glen is a
fourth-generation chef her
great-grandfather owned a 2-star
restaurant but Allen's talent was
discovered by three-star chef Alain
Ducasse who she interned with Sylvie
t-midi may I told me that I had what it
takes to become a chef gabroo and told
me to get started he gave me a lot of
encouragement and support so I thought
long and hard about it and then I
decided to take the challenge and she
had to work hard to get ahead in a
profession that's dominated by men there
are more than 100 3 star chefs worldwide
but only seven of them are women
including Italian chef Hanif a owed and
Spain's Carmen risk Aida
sivakasi da this is a very demanding
profession it's tough to combine it with
a marriage and a family you work until
late at night so you're never home to
put your children to bed or read them a
story and that would be really difficult
for a lot of women program or famous
journalist Alex allah has written a book
about the situation of France's top
female chefs he says things are
improving but real change will take time
well okay don't go this profession has
been dominated by men for a long time
and explained that there were several
reasons for this the pots were too heavy
aura was really hot in the kitchen and
besides having a woman in the old boys
club would stir things up cold welcome
all did he got through these days it's
not enough for a female chef to merely
have talent she has to prove that talent
and then work her way up before Bruce
Jenner surface i speak t olinda hose was
the inspiration for the tough-talking
female chef in a Disney movie how many
women do you see in this kitchen well I
only me why do you think that is well I
because how cuisine is a consecrated
hierarchy built upon rules written by
stupid old man move designed to make it
impossible for women to enter this one I
know that the screenwriters even flew to
Paris for extra insights animal as
bodies with City common in petite soeur
men know for weak people were coming to
the kitchen to watch my gestures filmy
not ask questions it gets Joe Mike City
I don't care who's your boss fight
whistle but I don't think I'm like the
chef in the film me Luca well maybe I
used to be more like her but nowadays
I'm not as tough anymore key key key
assume that's been a farmer woman with
all its advantages and disadvantages me
he says I don't terrify me before see if
I you'll see choir one oft cited reason
for the gender imbalance among
michelin-star holders is the difference
in styles well did he do Ernest are you
have to cook in a certain way you need
technical mastery and to be able to
create certain subtle flavors off
defenders that appeals more to men while
women prefer the straightforward
pleasure of eating
so please aveeno sap in a lens case that
resulted in creations like this porcini
with eel and garlic sauce or oyster
tartare with caviar
presented by a fight with the emotions
of a woman we have different
sensibilities than men it's something
you can see and taste is accessing
processor
michelin-starred chef manager and mother
of two daughters a challenge that she's
mastered she's far from the only woman
in her restaurant where forty percent of
the staff her female her next goal heart
from chalking up another Michelin star
is a new affordable restaurant with a
distinctly feminine touch